[Music]
that book was intended to do a number of
things one was to undermine the myth
that the best time of one's life is the
time between about eighteen and twenty
eight which is a myth
it's empirically wrong I hope you're
enjoying your lives right now I do
sometimes meet people in their twenties
who do and that's great
most people I know once they're out of
them would never choose to repeat them
again they're terribly difficult times
of our lives we're trying to figure out
who we are and what we can do what we
want to do and all of that and added to
that comes the voice of people their 40s
and 50s and 60s who say you know this is
the best time of your life enjoy it now
and then you think oh my god not only am
i miserable about you know my love story
or figuring out what job I want but this
is the best time of my life and I'm not
enjoying it you know and they've done
social psychologists have done studies
there's a so called you curve that
people start getting they get unhappier
and unhappier up to a point and then it
goes up again and it's different at a
rate for different in different cultures
but the one thing that we know
empirically is this is not the happiest
time of one's life so why are we being
sold this myth once again we're being
told be realistic which means accept the
world as it is the world is extremely
limited your choices within it are going
to be more limited still and you'd
better you know face up to it you'd
better resigned and you know we're
resigning means buying into a culture
that equates growth with having more
stuff I mean best for the economy but
also for you know people as individuals
and the goal in that book was to try to
provide a view of growing up which I see
as rooted incant the most important
difference that Kant drew actually it
wasn't just gone come but there's a way
in which he took it from David Hume
David Hume said there if there's a
complete difference between the is and
the ought so statements about what is
are completely different from statements
about what ought to be now
what Hume concluded from that is
basically there is no ought alright
because it has no basis in empirical
fact alright it's just you know comes
from even put in those terms but you can
call wish thinking or somebody's trying
to assert their power over you or
something like that and what content was
to say yeah these are two completely
different things
and they both have force and they both
have a claim on us and my argument in
that little book is being grown up
involves keeping one eye on the way the
world is and one eye on the way the
world ought to be and not confusing the
two but not giving up on either one
so yeah it is connected with some water
and then you can you identify who
creates the myth is it sort of a
capitalist myth or a woods man if that
we get from know so much other than that
actually I mean well look it's
interesting because it's it's very
Western and as I said in starting my
knowledge of other cultural
philosophical traditions is small but
I've read enough anthropology and seen
enough of the world to know that
traditionally and still in other
cultures that are not European it's
quite different they're not as child
focused you know growing up his is
something to aspire to and the really
interesting thing is no child wants to
stay a child it's children want to grow
up because they create they equate being
adult with being able to create things
having freedom being autonomous making
choices so how is it created look it's
also partly self created I mean it's
it's I wouldn't say like many important
ideologies that you know wicked people
sat around in a back room and said this
is how we're gonna screw people over no
ideology gets created that way and what
I find so interesting is that its self
supporting that it's a myth that people
buy into themselves it was really funny
when I was writing that book you know if
you're a writer and you see friends you
haven't seen in a while probably the
first thing they'll ask you is so what
are you working on these days and in
three different cases the reaction when
I said I'm writing a book called why
grow up he said ooh
is it what an awful subject and one of
them said to me my hero was always Peter
Pan well the funny thing is that all
three of these grownups
they're quite different it's also three
different countries but all of them
[Music]
fulfill my ideals of being a grown-up
they're all I guess now in their early
70s they're all working incredibly
actively in their chosen because there
are once an artist - I guess
intellectuals they're all politically
active one of them you know literally
physically outlines they're all
multilingual they're all I mean none of
them has not only has none of them
stopped being in the world they continue
to learn and they continue to give back
to the world and that sense of being
absolutely alive is what those people
equated with being childlike
oh I'm childlike no no now you're a
really successful grown-up although one
of them is completely unsuccessful in
conventional terms as the other two are
rather successful conventionally but so
it's a self-perpetuating ideology and
I'm doing what I can to work against it
for more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas her III TV
you